see number 62 getting loose so far this
season a couple of starts very high era
and very high walks nine strikeouts to
go along with those seven walks and so
as i mentioned a slow start here from
quintana three in the third and one and
two thirds that is how long he has
lasted in both of his starts
opponents hitting 370 against him coming
into this game here's the next pitch and
this is lifted in the air in the right
center field schedler has a beat on it
couple feet to his right and medium
right center to gather that one in and
that's the game's first out
and joey gallo will be the next batter
so two balls and two strikes
next pitch there's a swing and a miss
chased a sinker and that right there was
the best inning so far this season for
quintana in an angel uniform he has a
clean top of the first
mike fulton
29 years old initially back in 2010 a
houston astros first round pick did a
lot of things very well with the atlanta
braves it's a tough start this year for
the right-hander yeah he's got a real
good fast please 93-98 david fletcher
261 on base this year a couple of walks
eight strikeouts
he's got that one double and seven runs
batted in
david shoots that one bad luck nate lowe
right there a liner he was playing a
good
20 feet or so off the first base line
and didn't have to move an inch right
there that ball came right to him ohtani
so far in the series oh for four
so three two to ohtani and there's a
strike three call at the knees and
ohtani grimaces thinking the pitch was
either low or inside or both so jordan
baker who has a reputation as a strike
caller is living up to it in the early
going so here's mike trout batting two
outs no one on no score and he swings at
the pitch and lifts a high fly ball
that's carrying deep out into right
field it is trouble here
home run number six for mike trout
trotty going to right center early to
count damage first pitch power for
trouts sixth of the season 40th
of his career versus the rangers
it's on the outside part of the plate
it's down and that is right in the
launch so trout does not try to pull it
goes right with it
they play culberson straight up pick off
throw and this time garcia was leaning
and they've got him in a rundown he
won't give up easily though
and they finally
put the tag on him david fletcher
that's a caught stealing
quintana is ready and the 3-2 delivery
he got him swinging fastball it was a
little high and away struck him out and
that will end the inning
three strikeouts already against the
first six batters
any kind of decent hit here certainly an
extra base hit but even a long single
with leote on the move might play two
full count to nick sola here's the pitch
runners go and that is a called third
strike and solac knew it struck him out
looking
and quintana pitches out of a little bit
of trouble as the inning comes to an end
ohtani hitting 304.
shohei
hits a high fly ball to right field to
the wall
goodbye
by the way he's got a pretty good sprint
going around he won't even let us enjoy
that home run for shohei ohtani let's
get his sprint speed on that home run
for showtime
now his fifth home run
of the season
flying around the bases that was crazy
first of all the homer was crazy the man
is crazy a little showtime in the
daytime and he gets a slider gets
underneath it joey gallo the right
fielder gets the fence and just turns
around and watches it
so joey ends up hustling over to third
here on this pop-up opposite field
single for charlie culberson that loads
the bases for jonah hahn
and he swings here and he drives one
deep into left field upton is there
though he'll make the catch gallow tags
at third he comes in to score
a line drive sac fly to left for jonah
heim and the rangers are on the board
here at 2-1 for heim his second run
batted in
they'll take that
eli white walked was stranded back in
the third inning the
2-2 coming back our way up above did it
come in yes right there in front of you
where's the kids are there kids do we
see any kids kids kids there we go we
need kids yeah the little one right
there
right there that's great smile on the
little ones face baseball
justin upton strides towards home plate
2-1 is to score
justin upton toward the corner
that got over the wall and gone
upton cracked his bat on his knee the
first time up that one there he cracked
right out of the ballpark for a home run
humpton's fourth of the year 116.5
miles per hour exit velocity uptown funk
gone
ah look at that exhale that smile i
didn't think it had enough to get up and
get out but with that short wall that
wall's about four feet
down in that left field corner and it
just slides right over the top of it
danger lurks
because garcia though
he does have a single ground out on a
strikeout has home run power can do
damage here it comes
well struck
high in the air deep center field gone
garcia again
and adoles has put the rangers in front
of the eighth inning
he doesn't mess around with the
excitement in the celebration and this
is tremendous power from adolese garcia
enjoying the moment as much as anybody
as he should
pretty well struck out to right field
that one is gone
back-to-back home runs as nate lowe
joins the party
big insurance run and it makes it 5-3
rangers
second time the rangers have gone back
to back this year
cashing in the walks and now swinging
the bats and some momentum up and down
this lineup nate lowe jumping all over
very
a base is loaded spot for gallow and
then the man waiting on deck
adolesce garcia doesn't seem to have
bothered him at all the 3-1
and that's ball four he's just walked in
a run
wow what an inning solo's had a good day
he's been on three times a walk a base
hit the home
run no
oh a block
and the rangers will pick up another run
and that'll
ian kennedy on this ninth inning not a
safe spot for him
i fly ball center field tavares goes
back to the wall goodbye
iglesias touches them all he'll enjoy
that tour around the bases
there's one back
that's a ground ball shortstop backhand
connor felefa and it's in time to first
eight strikeouts no walks
john king got the win
and enough offense today